sometimes great moments are born not
from a perfectly executed display of
skill between two great players but from
a singular well time to blow and what
could otherwise be described as a
slugfest start moving forward there
don't Minds also to help out these
banelings become far more effective the
splitting looks immaculate a lot of
people say it's like the greatest game
of all time I don't know if I'd agree
with that I think it's neither of us
played perfectly but that made it more
exciting anyway bombers forced oh man
this medivac oh oh
other times those moments are created
when a player bucks the norm and plays
their way not the established so-called
the best way I don't know what you saw
all the throat and there's still several
banelings left over but in a few cases
it's a boat and we saw a perfect example
of one of those moments in Starcraft 2
when scarlet faced off against bomber in
a Red Bull battlegrounds New York City
2013 in late 2013 Starcraft 2 s heart of
the swarm expansion had been out for
more than eight months and for Zerg
players that meant playing a strategy
that involved swarm hosts a slow-moving
unit that could spawn locusts but while
swarm hosts were effective many people
didn't love the defensive play style
including Sasha Scarlett Austin for most
they were really bad for the game like
as is our Eclair you kind of had to play
this foremost yourself but it didn't
feel fun at all yeah it was just sit
there and slowly killed it with an
endless array as of four units but not a
good mechanic for sure instead she used
strategies that lean more heavily on
Serling's and muta lists mine does magic
catch it might not matter alive is now
back it's the production lights go it's
gonna win it in 2013 she was the great
foreign hope for Starcraft 2 she had a
couple exciting victories in his Koreans
already including an upset of MVP in
Gaea
pl-4 detonation of the bay leaves in the
ASEP line the harvester count down to 16
is out of 59 supply that's it
Gigi Gigi and Scarlett she has done it
and Red Bull battlegrounds 2013 Scarlett
found herself facing off against joy
bomber ji-sung a Terran player from
Korea who should play too many times
before he had a long been known for his
incredible macro but also for playing
excellently yet falling short of
Championships he was also somewhat of an
innovator early in 2013 in a game
against a go soon user he extended the
range of his Raven seeker missiles by
targeting an empty medivac and flying it
to Wharton's opponents units and now
brew votes are coming out as well the
greater spar has completed those
corrupters aren't Walter Kovacs oh wow
that was so good at this game
what did I just watch meeting between
scarlet and Ballmer resulted in what was
usually an exciting series oh my god
this push so important for a bomber
right now he's still suck on three bases
the banelings starting to connect Cam's
gonna break through her huge Rita last
bump coming in from the side but those
fries are 3-3 she has to be careful Oh
Bailey's rolling
let's enter the nucleus continue to
power back on here
Stalin trying to connect with everything
in sheep toes Palmer on the retreat I
actually lost him earlier in the year
and a really close to three series and
an important match I felt like I kind of
had that series and I threw it away at a
couple points so I felt like I could
definitely beat him a fight at Red Bull
her confidence was partially based on
the fact that she'd been playing against
Koreans in Korea for months which was
unheard of for Western Starcraft 2
players at a time her games against
bomber though tended to go along which
made for tense viewing but draining
games for the players the games would go
on a long time and it felt really close
the whole time or I felt like someone
was barely losing but no one was in a
clear advantage so like if you make one
big mistake the games just over and it
felt like that for like 15 20 minutes
straight at times and like their
previous series of the WCS season 2
finals this series was packed with great
moments scarlet has to be really careful
here mean bomber his timing is
fantastically one once done combat
shield um sim done
but transfuse to keep immunised alive a
dis coordinated attack a little wave
legs gets annihilated by that early set
a widow mines with scarlet is still
trying to control tutus nearing
completion for scarlet man the aunt line
of Marines has never ambition with a
perfect angle scarlet does not have
enough good game ug bombers so good
I think Scarlett's getting a little
overeager here Marcus I don't know if
this is the best move I don't know if
this is the best move but scarlet has
decided that she has to strike now the
surround on the zergling who are what
folded through and scarlet shatters it
wouldíve we're now looking at 157
supplied to the 77 of bomber and one has
to wonder like at what point is that
really proved oh the crowd goes nuts
Wow but Game three of the series would
become a legendary scarlet Rena can off
the reinforcements bombers worked
himself into a corner but there's still
not that many Zerg units here here come
the banelings is this the moment where
the remaining forces of bombers
disintegrates is this the moment where
the muta pack disintegrates it's unclear
and scarlet has barely broken through
with the supply cows still dead even Oh
94 to 67 and if you look at the army
supply 44 for scarlet 36 for bomber what
a game three and now he's walking right
onto creep territory yeah he is and he's
realized that hey we've got some bases
down here they need to be taken care of
some more paintings are gonna morph in
defensively this is where I wish I wish
wish wish there was burrow and you have
some defensive burrowed failings could
it go up anyway and we'll see how this
goes there's a couple of widow mines
there kill the packs all sense of units
being chipped away at is this the moment
where scarlet finally ceases the
aggression or where the expansion falls
and it looks like it will be the former
scarlet repels the attack once again but
a huge pack of bio continues to swarm in
trademark bomber macro how is this
possible one of them there
and it's all up to these banelings can
they deal enough damage 15 muta lists
trying to clean it up scarlet needs to
space but bomber target fires and he
takes it down Oh huge huge victory for
bobert after a tense back-and-forth
contest the game passed a 30 minute mark
and both players were mined out
effectively unable to get any more
resources and had to make use of the
unit's they had a left on the map we're
going on minute thirty two of this game
and this is one of the craziest TV Z's I
think I've seen in quite a while been
close to no base for everyone for a long
time the game hung in the balance and
with parts of bombers base under siege
he didn't have the energy he needed to
scan for burrows or units like
self-destructing banelings
I feel like banelings bourbonnais was
the perfect choice for that game because
he was losing a lot of its orbital so he
couldn't really scan to see them and I
knew that and also it's a very cheap
investment knowing her opponents boner
ability scarlet laid the devastating
trap this is a mouthy really close
Marcus burrow is done
that means burrowed banelings are going
to came to your Scarlett losing control
a little bit with the lift there this
could be a bomber can't afford to scan
so this burrow the Burrow Darren is huge
there just over to the right a little
bit more bring them out Batum destroy
the bait
to see what that kind of thing happens
chases event that's back in there's some
Bailey's here to reinforce as well but
that was what I gave you what a game has
Scarlett done it thirty Marines remain
it's a dead even fight Scarlett's been
on no basis I don't believe it the last
scans down there are no stands left
Scarlett is going to be on Burrell and
run she is killed off the last Oracle
command Scarlett refuses to engage
without the noodle list the Queen's
taking damage a queen falls but Scarlett
on the regroup is
I was so happy sure yeah I actually
jumped up out of my seat because I
couldn't really believe it I even went
over to one of the casters mr. bender
and started talking to him which is not
really normal to do out in the rain for
sure a lot of people say it's like the
greatest game of all time I don't know
if I'd agree with that I think it's
neither of us played perfectly but that
made it more exciting in a way
whether or not Scarlett thinks it was
the greatest game of all time seeing a
foreigner defeat a Korean in 2013 was
pretty rare and having trained in his
Koreans in Korea Scarlett had what she
needed to prevail but to do it in such a
tense game with both players pushed to
the limit that's something else entirely
and when those banelings erupted it from
the ground it gave Starcraft fans a
moment they would never forget beta
destroy the beat
[Applause]
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button